let's bring in t Kut now he's a
professor of public policy at the Doha
Institute for Graduate Studies thanks
again for joining us in the studio
clearly heartbreaking scenes watching
babies that potentially will have all of
those machines that are keeping them
alive turned off when the fuel Runs Out
potentially in the next few days uh Tom
not even babies I mean uh think about uh
kidney patients with kidney failure we
need dialysis chronic conditions uh
it's it's a disaster unfolding under the
watch of the International Community
remember the Gaza Strip before this
crisis was a very impoverished uh area
and it lacked so many things you know
and the health sector was not in a great
shape to start with you know before this
war and it it it relied ex extensively
on on on Aid or external assistance
especially through honor one un agencies
that served 70% of its population who
are originally refugees so it tells you
a lot about the size of the crisis now
with this vast destruction you know the
the blind destruction of everything
targeting infrastructure hospitals uh
the minist of Health uh just announced
that 10 or 15 I think if my U numbers
are correct hospitals have become
non-operational so this so it's it's
it's it's a tragedy it's it's a war
crime to Target uh civil facilities
hospitals schools shelters and this has
to stop the International Community has
to have a clear stand on this it went
too far it went too far but just on that
I mean we saw The Summit in Cairo a few
days ago where all the many of the world
leaders sat around uh and discussed some
of them not all of them calling for a
ceasefire but really feels like until
the US puts pressure on Israel that
nothing is going to be done to get more
humanitarian Aid a WID spread uh intense
scale back in there because 20 trucks
even 200 trucks is is nothing at this
point in time is it um I'm um I I I'm
not sure that nothing can be done even
with Arab states positions yes the
political positions they have taken so
far are in the right way they should
have condemned early the I mean they
could have taken harsher positions from
day one to stop the massacre but would
that have changed anything unless the US
actually do it because it seems like
Israel's only really listening to them
at this point positions without action
and leverage and and and of course I
mean it would not be enough but my I
think that Arab states can do more they
have excellent relations with the US
their key allies to the US and some Arab
countries have even diplomatic relations
with Israel and they have what soall
common enemies you know uh so yes they
could do more to stop this they are in a
position to exercise some leverage on
the us as a key allly to these Arab
states and Israel as well to stop this
uh this massacre I who who who in
particular are you do you want to see
step up here and actually push harder I
can name I can name countries I most
most G countries have excellent
relations with the US economic and
political Egypt has excellent political
key life for the US after the C David
peace agreement with Israel uh yes
Central and key Arab states yes they're
there and I mean when I saw when I talk
about Gulf countries countries like
Egypt these are Central countries in the
region and they have vast economic and
political influence over the us as well
so they could do more to stop this this
this this Bloodshed and protect
civilians at least bring ceas fire now
the top priority is ceas fire and then
everything else can be taken care of
gradually I understand that that the war
happened abruptly and Israel also is
very angry but keep civilian keep
civilians out of it civilians from from
both sides I'm not talking about
Palestinian civilians but Palestinians
in particular they need protection
because Israeli civilians have hospitals
to go to have shelter they don't have
this uh uh I mean I can't even compare
water and exactly exactly but Israel
also obliged by international law as an
occupying power also to take care of
Palestinian civilians under under
occupation and this includes the Gaza
Strip so it's not off hook of its
responsibility it is obliged by inter
law and once this war is over there will
be many big question Israel has to face
in the international I court of justice
and many International venu so let's
bring an end to this it's it's there's
no need to see this enough with the
Bloodshed it's really enough yeah well
there might not be a pause uh for
ceasefire at this point in time it does
seem like uh there are reports saying
that Israel could postpone its ground
Invasion waiting for more US troops
supplies to come into the region what do
you make of that is that a a viable
option here do you think that that is
actually going to happen or are they
buying themselves time there could be
many readings to this uh to I mean well
first of all let's let's recognize that
that a land Invasion into the Gaza Strip
it's not going to be a picnic trip for
Israel this is a very highly dense
populated strip and Hamas is is ready
and it will not be an easy War
whatsoever so I think the Israelis are
nervous uh probably the Americans are
nervous as well they don't want to see
another fuah uh remember Gaza is like 10
times the size of fuja in Ira So Pro
probably I I would assume maybe the
Americans are holding the Israelis back
and telling them listen think carefully
yes we're there to help you uh uh you
you have us supporting you you have a a
Lifeline of military supplies and
support coming to you so don't worry
we're not leaving you alone but again
think twice before entering Gaza Gaza is
not going to be a picnic for the Israeli
Army so probably there are so many
calculations now happening of course
like you know but these are all
speculations but I would think of this
scenario that even the Americans are
nervous of of of of the outcomes of a
land Invasion scenario and especially if
it goes so bad for Israel then it's
there's no return that's a permanent
damage yeah and then strategically the
US also has to think on how to put
brecks on Israel as well how to restrain
Israel from taking an impulsive
uncalculated decision and then going
into a military Adventure that will open
parador book books for Israel as well so
thank you so much uh as you've been
speaking we've just seen a number of
large uh explosions there in Gaza as you
can see the smoke blowing above the
strip clearly Israel at this point in
time showing absolutely no restraint
when it comes to the continuing
bombardment of
Gaza